aujourd'hui les amis nous allons piéger
les clients d'une boulangerie nous
allons tenter de faire croire à ses
clients que dustin est un vrai boulanger
vous êtes prêt au fonds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
destiny et la boulangerie ouvre dans
quelques minutes juste le temps pour lui
d' enfilé sa tenue de boulanger est-ce
que tu ne reçois d'austin jour soit cinq
sur cinq les mecs sache que tu as l'air
d'un vrai petit chef
arrêtez de déconner faut que je me
concentre les premiers clients arrivent
voyons voir comment justin va gérer ça
bonjour bonjour ça marche très bien pour
l'instant c'est un sans faute
je vous prends de ouaga de passe trop
cuites très bien ça fait 1 euros 90 s'il
vous plaît merci merci beaucoup merci au
revoir
bonne journée comment tu as eu les
baguettes qu'il fallait choisir bah j'ai
pris celle qui avait l'air le moins qu
on est bien jouer avec des amis de style
s'en sort à merveille depuis tout à
l'heure
personne ne s'est rendu compte du
subterfuge bonjour bonjour monsieur mais
regardez bien ce qui va se passer
maintenant
je vous prends une baguette tradition
souple et très bien tout de suite
monsieur vous êtes nouveau ici non
no stress surtout pas de steen merde
mais qu'est-ce qui peut répondre
[Musique]
wii 2
oui je me disais aussi que j'en ai versé
parfait de merde
applaudissez l'artiste nous a foutu une
de ses fruits' la frousse de l'année
[ __ ] bien jouer les mecs tout le
monde te prends pour un vrai boulanger
le piège a fonctionné à merveille et je
me cache pas que j'ai bien stressé mais
je me suis pas fait démasquer
je pense que la personne qui veut
démasquer la team full atx et c'est une
mission accomplie pour la team fou
encore une fois tout le monde n'y a vu
que du feu là je me suis fait piéger
pour la télé les noms mais j'ai pas vu
alors je n'ai pas vu de de quoi que
c'était pas le c'était pas le boulanger
le boulanger habituel on est vraiment
c'est le grand bras quel est le cas les
intérêts du coup parce que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puis création j'ai l'impression que vous
avez vraiment pris votre pied non alors
abonnez vous et rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour des caméras cachées
encore plus délire
[Musique]